corea del sur dice que un proyectil que
se cree que es un misil balístico de
alcance intermedio fue lanzado desde la
provincia de norcoreana de jagan lo que
está sucediendo es similar al periodo en
el que aumentaron las tensiones por los
lanzamientos de misiles balísticos de
intermedio y largo alcance en 2017 esto
puede verse como un acto que violan las
resoluciones del consejo de seguridad de
la onu tokio dijo que el misil alcanzó
una altitud de 2000 kilómetros y voló
una distancia de 800 kilómetros antes de
aterrizar fuera de la zona económica
japonesa generando preocupación las
actividades de corea del norte incluido
el lanzamiento de misiles balísticos es
una gran amenaza para la paz de nuestra
nación la región y la sociedad
internacional el lanzamiento de un misil
balístico de alta intensidad viola las
resoluciones del consejo de seguridad de
la onu y protestamos enérgicamente ante
corea del norte este mes se han
realizado siete pruebas de misiles
norcoreanos incluyendo lo que pyongyang
dice que fue el lanzamiento de misiles
hipersónicos el aumento de tensión en la
zona no se veía desde 2017 cuando corea
del norte realizó múltiples pruebas
nucleares y lanzó sus mayores
es difícil tener ya algún sentimiento
sobre estas pruebas yo solo pienso lo
están haciendo de nuevo corea del norte
realiza demasiadas pruebas el líder
norcoreano kim jong boom se comprometió
en diciembre a una modernización militar
y washington impuso nuevas sanciones en
respuesta
pyongyang indicó la semana pasada que
podría poner fin a una ley moratoria
sobre las pruebas nucleares y de largo
alcance que comenzaron en 2018